okay let's begin with the basics one
woman is an awesome film
I saw it on an opening night with my
wife as a DC Comics Pan Wonder Woman has
become one of their three most iconic
characters along with Batman and
Superman he's a driving force in their
universes she should be film does an
excellent job of laying out her origin
story and a beautifully balances the
feminist underpinnings of her character
she comes from a society in which men
are disdained and is eminently more
powerful than any man she comes across
in the non domestic Arab world with
obvious femininity to true heroine in
the film she fights for the innocent
she's willing to kill in order to do so
she is far harder core than Batman for
example she's a feminist for certain she
scoffs at the notion of a secretary as a
sort of modern form slavery at the same
time she goes out of her way to COO at
babies yes
feminist women like babies and she falls
head over heels for a heroic man despite
her own statements about men being
unnecessary for pleasure early in the
film she touched the notion of marriage
as does he by the end of the film
they're both on board plus she's played
by the wonderful gal gadot a two-time
mother who's pregnant Saar in filming
and just happens to be Israeli she also
served in the Israeli Defense Force for
two years all of this makes her
character unpalatable to hardcore
feminists who made feminism not on a
quality of right but on abortion and
man-hating and forceful opposition to
Western standards of beauty here's
Christina Cowdery G at tool a quote to
me whenever trans Wonder Woman had of
being some kind of feminist antidote to
the overabundance of superhero movies
made by and for Bros was blown by
prevailing occupation with a titular
heroine sex appeal how to reach even
implies that crisp lines character a
quasi rape Diana because both our
capacity for consent is somewhat blurry
her never having met a man and on here's
dude feminist Steven rose at the
Guardian quote the film fields obligated
to give prime his own equally heroic
story are men might be unnecessary for
pleasure but they're still essential for
big-budget action movies it seems plus
one woman fights against the Germans in
World War one this makes her an emissary
of American militarism on Tuesday
Josefina Livingstone wrote at the New
Republic Wonder Woman has no use for
global history except as course for
American exceptionalism
oh no we mustn't teach the young ones
about the fact that the United States
saves Europe from fascism twice that
would be terrible
most feminists seem pretty enthused
about the movie overall it should be
said but the fact that many are not
should show how out of touch the radical
feminist movement has become the film is
great for teenage girls
was clearly a fantasy nobody man or
woman could rush through bullets of
World War one in the way Wonder Woman
does but it's men who typically do the
fighting and war and rational reasons it
does demonstrate that strong women need
not be anti baby or anti male one of the
reasons the movie went over so big is
that its brand of feminism is taken for
granted in the West sexism is no longer
a major issue in American society it's
hard to imagine anyone seriously
objecting to a fantasy female character
fighting baddies while kissing babies
and falling in love with a strong male
character in traditional fashion that's
what feminism should be but not
according to the more militant feminists
which is why they're so mad for no
reason at all i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show okay so lots to get
to today we're going to get to
everything call me related in just a
second but first i want to say thank you
to our friends over at lyft so it's not
just for people who are looking for a
ride anymore now they're looking for
drivers because so many people are
riding lifts that they actually have a
shortage of people who can drive it's
they're asking you to join the
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating its people better when you
drive for the right right sharing app
every trip feels great and with lip you
can pick your own hours you can work
when you want
there's tipping in the apps you get paid
better when you drive for lyft you keep
100% of the tips drivers have been paid
over a hundred and fifty million dollars
in 50 since this feature was introduced
express pay means the drivers get paid
almost instantly instead of waiting for
weeks for a check to come in the mail
and right now they even hicken the
guesswork out of pickups they have an
EMP device that uses color coding to
help passengers find their drivers you
can earn hundreds of million and
hundreds of dollars a week plus tips if
you want to make more money Drive more
it's never been easier to give yourself
a race so go use lift my wife uses lips
i use lips the only ride-sharing app
that we use and i know the driver seemed
happier the drivers are always very
friendly they're always really good and
you can be one of those drivers are
earning really good money if you go to
lift calm slash shapiro today and right
now if you do that go to lift calm slash
shapiro today
you can get a $500 new driver bonus
right off the bat that's lip comm slash
shapiro lip comm / 0 ly ft.com
/ shapiro it's a limited time only terms
apply again use Shapiro so that you know
that we sent you and also because that
means you'll get that five hundred
dollar new driver bonus ok tons to get
you today with regard to the comité
hearing so I will get
what exactly Comey said in the hearing
that is relevant and interesting but
first I want to go through the part that
actually is most important and that is
the seven page piece of testimony that
he released yesterday so yesterday he
releases text of testimony that he
wanted to admit it into the
Congressional Record what he says
happened between him and President Trump
now in order to understand this what you
have to understand first and foremost is
that the Democratic narrative going into
this entire Comey hearing is that
President Trump colluded with Russia
during the 2016 election in order to
swing the election to himself and then
he fired Comey in an attempt to cut it
up in order to cover it up that was the
entire narrative the narrative was that
okay it wasn't just Trump acted badly it
wasn't just Trump obstructed justice
about unrelated matters it was that
Trump was in bed with the Russians and
then in order to cover it up he fired
James Comey in order to obstruct the
investigation that was the case
Democrats were making and the reason
they were making this case is because
they didn't want to seem like Hillary
Clinton legitimately lost the election
they wanted it to seem like Hillary
actually won the election if not for
Trump moving with Putin in concert and
therefore he has moving food and in
concert they they were colluding
together the election was rigged and
then from fired Comey to prevent all
that from coming out that was their
narrative so yesterday James Comey
releases the 7 page document and it
totally destroyed that narrative it
totally destroyed that narrative so the
right is pointing out that it totally
destroyed that narrative on the other
hand it also points out that President
Trump is wildly in over his head when it
comes to dealing with his own people
that he acted really badly with regard
to James Comey the FBI director on a
variety of matters in ways that would
tick us off if we were on the left it
would take us off and I'll explain how
we know that in just a second but first
I think it's important to go through the
actual documents we're now going to go
through the text of the opening
statement that Comey gave on Thursday
okay so today he was supposed to give us
he's nationally reading into the record
he didn't have to had already been read
by everybody in America so he started in
this document by describing his first
meeting with then president-elect Trump
on January 6th at Trump Tower and which
he personally briefed Trump about an
intelligence community assessment
concerning Russian interference in the
2016 election this is the same BuzzFeed
da that was supposed to have the P tapes
in it and all of this so Comey comes to
the
or rather to Trump Tower and he tell us
from about this day he says he briefed
Trump on the details himself alone out
of respect for Trump's privacy Comey
explained he was worried that the
briefing might believe might lead Trump
to believe that the FBI was
investigating him so he wanted to assure
from that Trump was not being personally
investigated now as you recall when
Trump fired call me he had in his letter
that Comey had said he was not being
personally investigated three times that
was true Comey says that in this
document
Comey told Trump over and over and over
again he's not being personally
investigated so that part is actually
true in what Trump had to say okay so
this confirms Trump's account then
according to government he spoke with
Trump one-on-one nine separate times in
four months three in person six on the
phone the next meeting that Comey
discusses in detail is that January 27th
dinner you remember Trump went on
national TV he said that Comey basically
came in and begged for his job and then
there were reports that Trump had asked
for me for a loyalty oath you want to
Trump Trump won and Comey to pledged his
loyalty to Trump here is commis account
quote it turned out to be just the two
of us seated at a small oval table in
the center of the greenroom
two Navy stewards waited on us only
entering the room sir food and drinks
the president began by asking me whether
I want to stay on as FBI director which
I found strange because he had already
told me twice in earlier conversations
that he hoped I would stay and I had
assured him that I intended to
he said that lots of people wanted my
job and given me abuse I had taken
during the previous year he would
understand if I wanted to walk away my
instincts told me that the one-on-one
setting and the pretense that this was
our dispersed discussion about my
position Mensa dinner was at least in
part an effort to have me asked for my
job and create some sort of patronage
relationship this concerned me greatly
given the FBI's traditionally
independent status in the executive
branch okay so this is the part where
Trump gets into dicey territory so I'm
227 meets with Comey
and he says to him you have your jobs no
chip be paid if that job went away
wouldn't it and Comey took that as
you're basically asking me to do
something for you
the president said quote I need loyalty
I expect loyalty I didn't move speak or
change my facial expression in any way
during the awkward silence that followed
we simply looked at each other in
silence the conversation then we've done
but return to the subject near the end
of our dinner at one point I explained
why it was so important
that the FBI and the Department of
Justice the independence of the White
House I said it was a paradox
throughout history some presidents have
decided that because problems come from
Justice they should try to hold the
department close but blurring those
boundaries ultimately makes the problem
worse near the end of our dinner the
president returns the subject of my job
he then said I need loyalty
I replied we will always get honesty
from me he paused them and said that's
what I want honest loyal T I paused men
said you will get that from me as I
wrote in the memo I created immediately
after the dinner it is possible we
understood the phrase honest loyalty
differently but I decided it wouldn't be
productive to push it further so this is
obviously not said for Trump right it
looks like there's some sort of quid pro
quo here he wants to call me loyalty in
exchange for Comey staying on the job
okay next meeting Comey discusses we're
just going to go through commis
testimony and then were going to talk
about what it means Comey moves on to
this February 14th counterterrorism
briefing Trump this is the one where
Trump apparently shoes everybody out of
the room leave shoes attorney General
Sessions out of the room he shoes rod
Rosenstein out of the room he shoes out
the NSA Rogers who chews out the DNI who
shoes out everybody and then he talked
to Flynn he talks to Comey one-on-one
and hears Comey Jackman he says Trump
repeated that Flynn hadn't done anything
wrong on his calls with the Russians but
he had misled the vice president he then
said I hope you can see your way clear
to letting this go to letting sin go he
is a good guy I hope you can let this go
I replied only that he is a good guy he
said I did not say I would let this go
the president returned briefly to the
problem of leaks goes on because I
immediately prepared an unclassified
memo of the conversation about Flynn and
discussed the matter with FBI senior
leadership I had understood the
president to be requesting that we drop
any investigation of Flynn in connection
with false statements about his
conversations with the Russian
ambassador in December I did not
understand that the president to be
talking about the broader investigation
into Russia or possible links to his
campaign in other words the Democratic
narrative that Trump was trying to fire
Comey or pressure call me to stop the
Russian investigation altogether just
not true even according to Comey that's
commis testimony so Comey says he wanted
him to stop talking about Flynn
generally he wanted him to stop
investigating
Flynn over his Russian phone calls in
December but nothing to do with the
campaign so the press is trying to say
that again this is a cover-up an
obstruction of justice by
the question is what exactly is being
obstructed so if you want to say that
there is some sort of pressure going on
with regard to Flynn and the December
phone calls which again there's no
underlying evidence that anything wrong
happened in those phone calls but if you
want to say that Trump was upset with
those in the investigation those phone
calls me is pressuring combing that
seems fair but the media were not making
that cake the media were making me far
different and more and more brutal case
basically that President Trump was
trying to shut down the entirety of the
Trump Russia investigation by pressuring
combing this means there is still no
evidence that Trump cares about quashing
an investigation into campaign collusion
according to combing the conversation
was not reported to attorney general
Jeff Sessions Comey says because
sessions is about to recuse himself and
then he says quote the investigation
moved ahead at full speed so again from
a a pressure Comey bakoma obviously
didn't take it sitting down and didn't
just stop investigating shortly
thereafter according to Comey yes
sessions provide a barrier between Comey
and Trunks and I told the AG and what
had happened him being asked to leave
while the FBI director who reports to
the AG remain behind was inappropriate
and should never happen he did not reply
and then he said I did not talk about
the general Flynn stuff okay next Comey
talks about a March 30th phone call here
is his description quote on the morning
of March 30th the president called me at
the FBI
he described the Russian investigation
as a quote cloud that was impairing his
ability to act on behalf of the country
he said he had nothing to do with Russia
had not been involved with hookers in
Russia and had always assumed he was
being recorded when in Russia he has
what we could do to lift the cloud I
responded we were investigating the
matter as quickly as we could and there
would be great benefit if we didn't find
anything to our having's under work well
he agreed but then re emphasize the
problem that this was calling that this
was causing him now here is the key so
that in and of itself sounds damning
right it sounds like Trump wants Comey
to lift the cloud by killing the Russian
investigation but that's not what Comey
goes on to say what Comey goes on to say
is quote the president went on to say
that if there were some satellite
Associates of his who did something
wrong it would be good to find that out
but that he hasn't done anything wrong
and hoped I would find a way to get it
out that we will not investigating him
he finished by stressing the cloud that
was interfering with his ability to make
deals for the country so this has been
my theory since May and I was right all
along
my theory since calm
spired was very very simple President
Trump wanted Comey to come out and
publicly say that President Trump
himself was not guilty of anything
or under investigation Comey wouldn't do
it the reason that Comey said he
wouldn't do it is he was afraid that in
the course of the bigger investigation
Trump's name would come out and then he
would have to correct himself the same
way he did with Hillary Clinton back in
2015 so better to say nothing right now
than to come out and take Trump's not
under investigation and then come out
later and say Trump is under
investigation okay
that being the case that means that
Trump was not firing Comey because he
wanted Comey to stop the investigation
into Trump he was firing Co me because
she was just mad that Comey wouldn't
come out and say publicly when Comey had
already told him privately which is that
Trump was not personally under
investigation
I see arised that all the way back on
May 10th that is exactly correct that is
exactly correct
okay so again is this Trump behaving
well no it's not Trump behaving well
okay in the end but is it also does a
drive with left's narrative that Trump
was colluding with Russia and then fired
Comey to cover it up no this is not
Drive in any way there's no evidence of
collusion that entire narrative is
destroyed by James Comey okay finally
Comey turns to a phone call that took
place on April 11th here is what he says
quote Trump replies the cloud was
getting in the way in the way of his
ability to do his job he said perhaps he
would have his people reach out to the
Acting Deputy Attorney General I said
that was the way his request should be
handled I said the White House should
contact the leadership of the DOJ he
said he would do that and added because
I have been very loyal to you very loyal
we had that same you know I did not ask
him or reply what he meant by that thing
I said only that the way to handle it
was to have the White House Counsel
called the Acting Deputy Attorney
General okay again the conversation
about that thing sounds dirty it sounds
like Trump is trying to get something
out of Comey in exchange for something
else right that is the thing that they
have okay and one of the speculations is
that Trump had mentioned deputy FBI
director Andrew McCabe and Trump
pertaining him even though McCabe it has
went to Democrat as sort of a favor to
come me and then call me treating him
nice because he was nice to call me by
keep it allowing him to keep his job and
keeping the cave in his job but again
there is no actual evidence of collusion
between Trump in Russia and once again
there is no evidence that Trump was
trying to quash the investigation into
Trump what Trump wanted out of the toll
thing was something very simple he
wanted Comey to come out publicly and
say what he had said privately which is
that Trump was not personally under
investigation that is the entirety of
the whole thing from fired him because
he wouldn't do it he fired him because
he wouldn't do it now that is the issue
with regard to Trump Russia and that's
why the right today is chortling and
they're saying okay you guys making the
case for half a year now about the term
pressure collusion and you were saying
that Trump is at fault for trying to
fire at homee as it's some sort of giant
cover-up or something okay you say all
of that but then there's no actual
evidence of any of that so call me just
destroyed you now here is what the left
is saying what the left is saying is we
know that Trump basically quasi offered
Comey a quid pro quo we put pressure on
him and he he mentioned his job he's
putting pressure on him to to leave the
Flynn investigation alone he was doing
all of these things and if Obama had
done all this you would be really really
ticked off they're not wrong about this
okay if Obama had done this we would be
really ticked off how do I know because
today Comey and his detrol testimony
said the Loretta Lynch told James Comey
that she didn't want the Hillary
investigation referred to as an
investigation she wanted it referred to
as they matter and Comey said that
created the appearance of impropriety
between Loretta Lynch and Hillary
Clinton's campaign it certainly did
right all of us on the right were livid
about the fact that Loretta Lynch met
with Bill Clinton on the tarmac and they
talk about the Hillary investigation
we're all livid we said this create some
pride it does create impropriety just
like it creates impropriety for
President Trump to meet with the Acting
FBI director James Comey and tell them
who wants a flynn investigation wrapper
I hope the Flint investigation will be
dropped now is that obstruction of
justice no it's not technically
obstruction of justice because again
there was no actual threat to Comey that
if you don't drop this I'm going to do X
and it was not an actual you know real
attempt to get women instead to get
Comey to stop investigating Flynn it was
more like I hope you stopped that so
there are two ways to read that right
one is I really hope you stab that would
be a terrible thing something bad were
to happen to your children and the other
way to read that is I hope you can stop
this because it's really you know a pain
in the butt for me and purple in two
ways to read that you know again it is
not impossible to read it in the most
innocuous way but it is a little bit
strength if you're a Democrat you're
watching this you are saying okay Donald
Trump is obviously
doing dirty things if you are a
Republican watching that you're saying
it's not so obvious the Trump is doing
terrible obstruction of justice things
but exactly inappropriately for
presidents of the United States I want
to talk about what actually got said
during the hearing and how the media is
going to shift the narrative from its
original narrative in just a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
advertisers over at math Weldon so Matt
Weldon is better than whatever you are
wearing right now math Weldon makes
underwear
they make shirts that are naturally
antimicrobial which eliminate odor they
make socks and hoodies and sweatpants it
is most comfortable stuff you are ever
going to wear it losing smart design
premium fabric simple shopping you go to
map wells when you check out their gear
very easy to shop they're very simple to
shop there and I can tell you now I wear
their underwear and the underwear really
holds up I mean you watch other brands
of underwear 10 times already falling
apart I've worn my Mac well done
underwear just a thousand times at this
point and they are pretty much exactly
the same as when I bought them
SuperDuper comfortable all of their gear
looks fantastic you can wear out you can
wear in it performs well it's great for
working out it's great for going out put
a mask
well done calm and get 20% off when you
use the promo code Shapiro sha Piro
that's Shapiro sha Piro go to math
Weldon comm ma CK wel do and comm get
20% off using that promo code Shapiro
and no let them know that use the promo
code Shapiro obviously so they know that
we sent you and also so that you can get
that 20% off best underwear in the world
I mean really it doesn't get better than
Mack welding stuff ok so here is how
that so that that is what Comey
released in his 7 pages of testimony it
explodes the Democrat narratives that
Trump was pressuring Comey to drop the
Trump Russia investigation and it
explodes the Democrat narrative that
there was something deeply nefarious
going on with regard to with regard to
Trump being under personal investigation
Trump is not under personal
investigation Comey came out he said
when he left today's and Thome was not
under that that Trump was not under
personal investigation now all of that
said here is some of what Comey had to
say today so Comey came out and he
didn't read the 7 page statement that
had already been entered into into
testimony so instead he came out with
this very short statement where he
ripped Trump basically for firing him
and here's what he had to say this clip
the administration then chose to defame
me and more importantly the FBI by
saying that the organization was in
disarray that it was poorly led that the
workforce had lost confidence in its
leader those were lies plain and simple
okay so yeah there is saying that
basically Trump is a liar and he lies
about things all the time is big big big
fat liar okay so I think objectively
speaking Trump fibs a lot but this is
really more about commis ego right so
this is him saying well he was mean to
me he was mean to the FBI because the
FBI is in disarray and that's really
terrible to lie about me I do by job the
FBI does its job and that's really
terrible this is going to be the
headline the media gorons on to as the
Trump is a liar and Comey reiterates the
Trump is a liar in clip 14 again this is
all opinion type stuff but the media
which is now trying to build pull me up
in some sort of great truth teller again
they're going to weep on this to say the
Trump is just a liar in total this is
clip 14 I want to go through a number of
the meetings that you referenced in your
testimony and let's start with the
January sixth meeting in Trump Tower
where you went up with a series of
officials to brief the president-elect
on the Russia investigation my
understanding is you remained afterwards
to brief Imam again quote some
personally sensitive aspects of the
information you relate now you said
after that briefing you felt compelled
to document that conversation that you
actually started documenting it as soon
as you got into the car now you've had
extensive experience at the Department
of Justice and at the FBI he worked on
the presidents of both parties what was
it about that meeting that led you to
determine that you needed to start
putting down a written record a
combination of things I think the
circumstances the subject matter and the
person I was interacting with
circumstances first I was alone with the
President of the United States or the
president-elect soon to be President the
subject matter I was talking about
matters that touch on the FBI's core
responsibilities and that relate to the
press
and President Elect personally and then
the nature of the person I was honestly
concerned that he might lie about the
nature of our meeting and so I thought
it really important to document that
combination of things I'd never
experienced before but it led me to
believe I got to write it down and it
got to write it down in a very detailed
way
okay so there's James Comey explaining
that he thought that Trump the big wire
so we have to keep all of the that we
have to keep all of these notes and
that's his explanation so the media is
jumping on the idea that Comey thought
Trump was a liar who cares whether Comey
thought Trump was a liar like he kept
these notes and then Trump even wider he
didn't so the media is jumping on
conclusions about looking at the
underlying evidence as usual I thought
Marco Rubio actually asked one of the
better questions of the hearing thus far
he said it's kind of amazing that all of
this material has leaked about Trump
from the intelligence community from the
Senate committee but there's one piece
of information that never leaked about
Trump and that is Trump was not under
personal investigation just as from said
that he was injured Marco Rubio making
that point we've learned more from the
newspapers sometimes than we do from our
open hearings for sure you ever wonder
why of all the things in this
investigation the only thing that's
never been leaked is the fact that the
president was not personally under
investigation despite the fact that both
Democrats and Republicans and the
leadership of Congress knew that and
have known that for weeks
I don't know I find matters that are
brief to the gang of eight are pretty
tightly held in my experience okay so
again I think that Rubio making this
point but is the right one it just
demonstrates that when it comes to be
bleach and it comes media this is a
motivated attempt to destroy President
Trump okay I want to talk about how the
left is going to pivot off of their
original narrative in just a second
right their original narrative again was
it was Trump rush or collusion they did
all this to save Hillary of course that
it was Trump pressure collusion and
that's why Hillary lost the election and
that's why Trump attempted to fire James
Comey was all as a cover-up Comey
totally destroyed that entire narrative
he explodes the entire narrative but he
comes out in size you think Strunk is a
liar and a bad guy okay whatever but
we'll talk about how the left is going
to pivot to their new line of
accusations which is a very different
line of accusations than the ones
they've already made but for that I'm
going to have to go over to Daily wire
comm and sign up $8 a month gets you
subscription to daily wire.com that
means you get the rest of this
that means you can be part of the
mailbag which will be doing it tomorrow
we are now five days a week this show
yay also mins to get Clavin show live
you get to be part of Clayton's mailbag
plus it means that we've got all sorts
of great benefits that are coming for
members that are going to be rolled out
in the next couple of months so stick
around for that if you're an annual
subscriber you get a signed copy of this
very book say it so into a book about
baseball and me and my dad there it is
there's my possum there's me and you can
get a free signed copy up say it so
right now it's available at Amazon for
sale they can get a free and sign right
now you've become an annual subscribers
so go over to daily wire calm and signup
it's an annual subscriber or if you just
want to listen to the show later go over
to iTunes and become a subscriber over
there and make sure you leave a review
we always appreciate it we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
Oh